chelsea
i know how to find tell me there is only
one person who knows how to find maui
you're not going anywhere without me why
someone has to make sure you don't kill
adria before you fight you can come if
you want
but adrien
[Applause]
i have vanquished jersey and his reapers
giving the people of westmarch their
city back
[Music]
lorath and i go to the blood marsh to
find
adria she knows how to locate
malthel she will tell me
and then she will pay in blood
for her betrayal
we hid the black soul stone in the
deepest part the nephilim ruins near
here
i consider myself an expert on all
matters concerning boguts
the bogut itself is a small odd creature
given to foraging and borrowing
under normal circumstances it fears you
can be incited to great violence when
under the influence of magical objects
rings in particular seem to excite them
this is the entrance to the tomb but
someone's collapsed it adria
it looks like we'll have to fight what
was that
still recharging
is a ferocious hulking beast with an
exceedingly bad temper
aided by packs of bogies it will fight
anything that crosses its path
invariably some of the boggets will die
but the survivors are rewarded with
scraps
i will not be late this time adria
remember to get the information we need
before you
right well that's really a sure
more fury
[Music]
these enemies defy all reasons
uh
this is one of the guide stones but
nothing happens when i approach it
let me try there are four the first time
i saw a witch
she burned father took me to the town
square to see it
look he said that is the face of
evil but she looked like any other woman
and burned like anything else
engulfed her her eyes found mine
and she laughed
this is not the passage i am looking for
this could be the right passage but i do
not know for sure
assistant was the noisiest creature in
the world but
that was before i discovered the
shrieking terror
this bat like monstrosity produces the
most ear splitting racket imaginable
and furthermore managed to make my
assistant scream even louder
i think my headache will last for weeks
now
now i know which side
this is the passage i have been looking
for
[Music]
i have always wondered how much adria
relied on diablo's power instead of her
own
based on her brother
these flesh gorges are raised from earth
stone and demon blood
and they are driven to feast on humans
so they may resemble us more closely
let's hope they don't succeed
ancient smile on youtube
the flesh shaman was created from the
blood of the witch adria
because of that the shaman is able to
use magic as she does
channeling the power of blood luckily
adrian
has so much blood
you're blessed
how taste your feet
me laura
this is as far as you go catch up to me
so
the ancient smile on me
you win against
these golems from the blood marsh their
bodies were formed from the water and
earth of the marsh itself while the
venom of the marsh creatures gave them
light
their very skin seems to burst over
your feet
always wanted
i grow stronger
i need fuel
not ready
my hand
[Applause]
[Music]
the ancient smiles
these ruins are strangely correct
my hands
no way
[Music]
oh
the ancient smile on me
i will not be nice
so
let's see where you've been hiding
raphael
adrian the angels will never suffer us
to live
they cannot accept the fact that we may
choose our
own path at least demons are not so
rigid in their beliefs
ugh
he always finds a way
i can't
[Music]
you never even suspected
more fuel
not ready
shoes
so
i need yuri
extinguished
[Music]
i have done what i can to ensure he
always finds a way in your heart of
hearts
you know this
before she died adria conjured and she
was searching for malphials
i need to go back
now we know no doubt he has gone now
they okay here's a couple
the only way